yeah welcome to this video playing a new
blitz game and for those of you that
think I'm trash-talking my opponents I
won't do that now because I play
teammate of mine and I feel I really
don't do that ever but ok this time
there won't be any air I need to have it
criticism alright so let's see him for
some reason about talking about this I'm
not into him rather stupid position here
Kings Indian attack sort of position
let's see I'm trying to get some play on
the queenside
hmm you probably play we should be 65
and so on so but when it can set up
reversed spacibo when you form yeah I
wonder if deform maybe it's a move hmm
yeah this is some pawn sacrifice in
various ways no black can't win a pawn
but I don't want to play too passively I
don't like 'if or something that's it
feels very passive yeah I can take on
before now but I thought that with them
with Ephraim I have some central play
yeah yeah I thought might be three
actually does should get it back if it
takes I don't get it back immediately
but this is two bishops and a good
structure ok so I i get the porn back
with this i guess or the other night the
other night you can actually take b3 and
don't let's not do that oh I'd like to
exchange the dark squared bishop
now I can actually take and play eve or
is this an idea why is this bad you
should give five looks a bit curious
yeah okay this this should be of the
right move community for I can also just
give this check on d4 first I can't play
efore I already you just drops bag so
let's let's centralize the Queen and no
I could play night g5 not sure that this
is a good idea now put that we concern
and we can sub structure was still a
form it is an excellent position in any
case okay let's do that
you always need to ask yourself okay is
this beneficial to me sometimes the H
valve can can be a problem but he
doesn't have any chance to him to ever
get Luke h eight and so on it's not not
really on and so I just have an
additional weakness i think on g5 to
play against my next move was just roped
you won some rook to d1 oh this is an
active defense okay I want to keep the
roof here in case of F for that I cover
the the Kings side a bit more rabid f5
really weakens and lots of squares
quick to be six the inviting movie yeah
it is inviting just when he played a six
like to go on this nice square attacking
b7 and detecting d6 so that I'm
threatening to to move the bishop and
then increase the pressure on the d6
form well now hard to keep material now
go into default yeah so that's just keep
it solid rookie form is it opened idea
to set up the zone there may be roped to
hear yeah this is good and Quinn to do
one okay maybe I can trick him h3
another the Queen covers that okay not
just shuffle a bit and now look again
I'd like to play h3a drew cage for
checkup it doesn't really really help
I need to take what the Queen
Queen B 6 that's not it's not easy it's
all nicely protected I always keep keep
some advantage here but winning is some
is another matter
don't really have a winning plan
that's very very drama still my can play
rock p6 at least them in probably needs
to decide at some point to jettison yeah
yeah immediately decided to jettison the
palm and this is probably a good
decision okay
time morning yeah it's a drone I didn't
even see that ook this is this is of
course really a troll now it's a drawing
any any kind of way yeah didn't didn't
really managed to draw correctly or we
just press them too many buttons yeah I
had some pool but see this is just good
defense you just got rid of this
weakness on it and gave up the pawn if
you if you defend this passively at it
it might be tricky yeah so and then this
is probably just the wrong he's got this
this active oops yeah I wanted to show
he's got this act upon it it limits my
king and i don't drive for any and he's
got this whole for the king it's it's
hard for me to make any sort of progress
that i basically need to run over with
my king without losing the hulking side
i think it so it's very dry and probably
am I needed to take my chances CM this
looks nice somewhere around here but
it's always a matter of precise plane
probably I should have played h 3 ER
Liam
yeah I always keep a little bit of
something but it's not it's not
clear-cut how to how to win probably I
need to play h3 it's also beneficial for
for most end games to get rid of this
apology for which is which limits
White's position here h3 maybe and then
we'll check don't know yeah thanks for
watching